make everyone how are you all
my name's Brady Haran and I make the
numberphile videos I also make several
other youtube channels which I might
talk about in a minute I'm not going to
be here for very long this is actually I
guess this is kind of a test run for me
I want to see how a few things are
working with the webcam and lights and
things like that I've been having all
sorts of problems and I'm also having a
computer new computer delivered so so to
show you just how live this is if the
door knocks I'm going to be out of here
very quickly because I miss the delivery
yesterday and I don't want to miss it
again the main reason I'm here is I want
to tell you about something like this
that I'm going to be doing tomorrow at
around the same time except away because
it's me sitting here I'll be I'll be
here with dr. James Graham who's in
loads of numberphile videos and we're
going to be doing bit of a live thing
where I'm going to ask him questions but
more to the point I'm hoping that you're
gonna ask him questions so if you do
nothing else please leave some comments
underneath this video with questions for
James and things for us to talk about
especially in case you can't make it
tomorrow I'll read your questions here
in the comments and try and make sure we
cover some of that stuff basically I
just want to make sure we've got
something to talk about from the start
so please leave any questions I'll
remind you again about the James thing
because that's the most important thing
that I want you to take from this and
we're going to be doing it at 4 p.m. UK
time which is 11 a.m. on the East Coast
in America 8 a.m. on the west coast in
the US and 2:30 a.m. if you're in
Adelaide Australia where I'm from I
always like to give things in Adelaide
times well tune in for that
I'll see if you've in the meantime you
can ask me any questions quickly now
let's have a quick look at your I'm
having a quick look at some of your
comments there's lots of them basically
saying hello say hello here we go did
you hear about a French podcaster who
talked about you know I did I didn't
what do you think about Russia I've
never been to Russia but I would like to
go for periodic videos because periodic
videos is my chemistry channel for
people who don't know about
and the periodic table what we see has
its birth in Russia so we do plan to go
there sometime and make some periodic
videos having a quick look people are
asking me about numbers and mathematics
that's probably not such a good idea
because I'm not a mathematician or a
meth sex for tomorrow James will be here
that will be a good time to ask some of
those questions perhaps James Gras I'm
asked which one is James grime he's he's
in the most numberphile videos you can
go back and have a look who he is but
he's really good value now how many do
you have how many how many channels do I
have I guess that means I think there's
about 12 channels numberphile deep sky
videos periodic videos sixty symbols
Nottingham Science Bible Dex words of
the world back stage science my favorite
scientists philosophy far sIFR essay
words of the world hey Brady greetings
from Spain so the last video I put up
was the one about statistics in football
I live in the UK and I do call football
football although I am from Australia so
I grew up calling it soccer I've had a
lot of comments about that so I thought
I'd discuss that as well a lot of people
don't like it when I call a soccer and I
I don't know I think it's kind of the
right thing to do I said at the start of
the video it's football but some people
call the soccer and then I call it
soccer a few times
soccer obviously being a shortening of
association football apparently and I
think it's okay to call that soccer in
that context I mean a lot of numberphile
viewers are American and Australian and
I think if I say soccer everyone knows
what I'm talking about and if I start
saying football all the time some people
don't and they might get confused so I
don't think there's anything wrong with
a few soccers in there amongst the
footballs
I know people feel passionately about it
but there you go
and another thing I get asked a lot
about is the brown paper in numberphile
videos so I thought I'd quickly discuss
that I've written a blog about this my
blog if I want to look it up is called
periodic videos blog or blogspot if you
just google periodic videos and blogger
you'll find my blog and if you google
periodic videos and brown paper you'll
firm the blog that I wrote about this
and I always point people to it but let
me talk it quickly through the brown
paper basically when I started
numberphile I knew there was going to be
a lot of writing involved from the
people in the film's the mathematicians
and scientists and other guests and I
wanted to make that a feature of the
videos I considered blackboards I
considered buying little slates and
short boards because I thought that
might be nice but in the end I thought
that would be messy and wouldn't work
very well there were lots of reasons it
wouldn't work when you wipe them out
they look really messy unless you clean
them really nicely and in the end I kind
of abandoned that I hate whiteboards
they also the pretty mucky when you when
you rub them off but also just what was
just remind me of corporate conferences
and school and I don't really want
numberphile to be like that obviously
you could do something with electronic
tablets and whatnot but I thought that
might be a little bit Karin Academy and
I quite liked the idea of brown paper I
didn't like the idea of white paper
because this is another reason white
boards aren't too good a really white
backgrounds not very good for filming
when you're filming people's faces and
the whiteboard it becomes very difficult
to control certain aspects of the
picture while you're filming whereas
sort of brown paper is a bit nicer for
that and I also just like the kind of
the rustic rich ruggedness of the brown
paper that kind of back of an envelope
napkin type feel that I'll at
numberphile to have I like it to feel
very informal and I also really like the
idea of being able to keep their
artifacts afterwards initially I was
putting them all on to Flickr and I
still put a lot of them onto Flickr if
you look at the number 5 Flickr you can
go and look at previous bits of paper
we've used also lately I've started
putting a few of them on eBay for
various reasons to either raise money
charity or to raise a bit of extra money
for some of the things we do with
numberphile that costs money I've got
some here yes here's a whole bunch of
brown papers from some previous some
upcoming videos so I've started keeping
them I used to throw them away after
they'd been scanned and put under Flickr
and now I realize that some people quite
like them and would like to keep them so
so I'm hanging on to as many as I can
and occasionally I'll give one away or
put one on eBay for some reason so keep
an eye out for that kind of thing on
Twitter and Facebook and whatnot so
anyway there are a few other reasons I
quite like brown paper I won't go into
more now I know some people don't like
the noise of the markers on the brown
paper and we've changed the marker since
the start because the first markers we
use for a bit of a mistake and also I'm
trying to do a bit more with the sound
editing but yeah anyway I'll have a look
at more of your comments for a moment
out of focus that's interesting I am
experimenting with the camera and I'm
having a few problems the lights as well
causing flicker so if you want to put if
you want to do some more comments but
any problems with the camera at the
moment I'll be looking back over this
video and trying to sort out so kind of
apologies it's a bit of a learning curve
yaght you guys are helping me lad now
you sponsored by a brown paper company
no but if you know one put them in touch
think I mean I'm being asked things
about Planck length from the speed of
light and again that's one for the
people I interview more than more than
me sorry about the focus I'll I'll work
on that then again if you watch my
videos you probably used to things being
out of focus now you
what about a channel about computer
science that's something that some
thought has been given to Australia has
many things called football
I do call it football at home by the way
uh-huh
or home now that I live in the UK
greetings from Israel hello Israel if
you watch my Bible decks channel we
actually went and filmed a whole bunch
of videos in Israel which I really
enjoyed I really enjoyed it there how do
you manage so many channels I don't I
don't know it's hard work what time will
the stream start tomorrow I'm glad you
asked and again that's the point of this
whole video that I'll be here tomorrow
with James grime hopefully more in focus
after I played with the camera some more
that's tomorrow Valentine's Day yes I'm
spending Valentine's Day with James
we're also going to be making a bunch of
numberphile videos beforehand so and
then and then we'll be doing this so we
might be able to tell you about what
we'd filmed beforehand so you hope you
have an exclusive tomorrow Valentine's
Day February 14 2013 4 p.m. in the UK
you can do the math for most other
people notice I call it math there they
are American viewers that's 11 a.m. on
the East Coast in the US 8 a.m. on the
west coast and 2:30 a.m. in Adelaide and
a reminder if you don't get to watch
live well you'll be able to watch the
recording at your convenience and also
if you want to ask a question you can
put the question in this comment section
and I'll be reading through this later
on with my hand over my eyes judging by
some of the comments and I'll take some
of the better comments and interesting
questions and throw them around with
James I'll just refresh the comments
hear from you guys I'm from India hello
we've done well have also filmed in
India if you watched periodic videos the
chemistry journal we've done a whole
bunch of films in India
have you ever been to Austria my
brother-in-law is Austrian and I have
been to Austria many times and I've been
to his home village of San Johan in the
Tyrol several times where he and my
sister ski very well and I ski very very
badly can you please do more philosophy
file videos I bumped into the people
from philosophy just today and we were
discussing that and we'll try and get
some more soon in hopefully later in the
year maybe it just depends on time and
other factors but I do enjoy doing the
philosophy ones and stay subscribe to
that one because there will be more
coming my fish doesn't have a name
people who come obviously call him Nemo
because he's a clownfish but I haven't
actually given this one a name but he is
a very Hardy very Hardy fish he in here
Hindu as allah some people are saying
the focus is far and i don't know i did
notice it dropping in and out a bit but
i'll go back and have a look i'm trying
my best
all this technology do a meet up with
people at nottingham university with the
professors who you do the videos with
someone says we have done one video
which had professor Polyakov from
chemistry professor mira field who was
in deep sky videos and sixty symbols
Professor Moriarty and professor
Copeland and I had the four of them
sitting their life in a firing squad and
I think we did that on the periodic
videos channel or the sixty symbols
Channel I can't remember which but it
wasn't that long ago and I'll put the
link if I remember in the description
for this video when this video becomes
like an archived video but you can go
and watch those guys and we have got
plans to do more this year which is half
the reason I'm sort of testing this
camera my computer has arrived
think I'll be right back
you
he's part 1 he's just gone back to his
trap to get the other part I shall
return I'm very excited
oh man there we go you might be able to
tell from the box what it is but I'm not
gonna discuss it because I don't want to
start one of those conversations I'm so
sorry about that this is the joys of
lower broadcasting but I wasn't going to
miss that delivery after missing it
yesterday so I'll have a quick look at
the quick look at it more comments for
those who have just joined us for those
who just joined us and were greeted by a
blank screen I'm sorry I was just taking
delivery of a computer that I've been
waiting for for a few days and this is
bit of a test run that I've been doing
sorry I'm a bit um puffed out now from
running after that computer this is a
bit of a test run we're doing a live
hangout tomorrow with dr. James grime
he'll be sitting here with me if you
want to ask any questions you can join
us tomorrow you can put in some
questions now tomorrow
14th of February 4 p.m. UK time 11 a.m.
Eastern us 8 a.m. Western us 2:30 a.m.
at the later time I was going to update
the comments putting comments here is
like dropping rubber ducks into a fast
flowing stream I know what you mean
I like the Eiffel Tower like yeah you
probably joined him we're just looking
at the Eiffel Tower on the wall sorry
about that
he's getting a new computer he's getting
it from a delivery guy
sorry about that Mac or PC let's not go
there at the moment Mac or PC what
you've up to fish I did leave you alone
with the fish I'm really sorry about
that I'm just finding out if there's
anything else I can answer for you no
where did you complete skull England or
Australia I completed school in
Australia if you watch periodic videos
we did a film where I actually went back
and met my chemistry and physics teacher
called mr. Janowski that's a video you
can watch livestream the unboxing I'm
not going to do that I'm not even going
to set up the computer for a couple of
days I'm so worried and intimidated by
the idea of trying to get my whole life
from one computer to another that you
wouldn't want to watch her laughs
greetings from Finland I won't be taking
an unboxing video is zero an even number
now I have said that I'm not a
mathematician but I can tell you that
zero is an even number because we did a
video about that I think I think I'm
back it'd be the end of the comments I
think that's everything for now that's
probably do you greetings from Germany
do you speak German nein greetings
I lack everyone puts greetings from
their country do you have a pet yes I do
have a pet I have my fish and I have a
dog that I will a dog bit it's not very
good at coming hang on
Lily no come here come here come here
come here
this is my pet oh yeah this is Lulu
she's a retired racing greyhound what's
that
she has appeared in several videos for
the eagle-eyed among you
the first Yahtzee video she ate this
number spaghetti at the end of yeah yeah
when is Phil coming back I'm seeing
Professor Moriarty on Friday with the
when we're planning to film some
numberphile and sixty symbols videos
more more probably more sixty symbols
ones I think we have planned yeah
remember remember the main point of the
comments section here as well as to even
if you watch this later on and you're
not watching it live put some comments
for for James tomorrow so we've got
something to talk about have you ever
played minesweeper what are your best
times I have played - way further quite
a long time ago and I can't remember any
of my times what was your favorite
subject in school I liked maths and
physics and chemistry
I also liked English I always wanted to
be a journalist I always wanted to be a
newspaper journalist and a writer so I
also really liked English how long have
you been interested in number facts I
think I've always been interested in
number facts
what was your first job my first job was
a cadet Journal store newspaper in
Australia are you ginger strawberry
blonde or mouse spray on you can decide
that one what are the specs for your
computer I can't even remember I ordered
that about a month ago please make a
video talk to your honor's of
astronomers about the Great Attractor I
think that's something we will do for
deep sky videos or sixty symbols quite
soon because I'm quite keen on the idea
of that one as well
greetings from Chile where we might be
travelling later this year what did you
do before these videos I used to work
for the BBC as a video journalist making
films for the news and before that I
worked in newspapers what got you in
video journalism I said I worked for the
BBC when I first worked for the BBC I
worked for the website and I was doing
lots of stories and things for the
website that they quite liked and they
thought that I should learn how to make
films about them as well so I so what I
was doing could also go on to the news
and television programs so they taught
me to be a video journalist what is that
golden orb behind you all that is I'll
pull it out just a little bit it's
actually a globe of the moon like an
earth globe except it's the moon and
it's it's like a vintage antique one so
it's matte it was made before they knew
what the other side of the Moon looked
like because obviously the moon always
has one face pointing towards the Earth
pretty much and for a long time we
didn't know what the other side looked
like until we got probes around there so
when you turn that globe around it's
like a map of the moon you turn the
background there's a big blank area
where it was unknown which of course is
very well known now I'll do one more
refresh of these comments 248 you should
do a video with minutephysics
well I have done some videos with
minutephysics if you have a look at a
video I did on sixty symbols I actually
interviewed Henry from minutephysics and
talked all about how he makes his films
and and Henry from minutephysics also
appears in our favorite number of videos
what football team do you go for I
actually support Liverpool for various
reasons although I live about 10 minutes
no I don't I live about I live about
five minutes walk from Nottingham
Forest's own ground would you like to do
a video with Vsauce I have done some
videos with Vsauce
he's actually set in this very chair in
one of the videos he's he's a very busy
man but he's a makes very good video is
very popular what university
you go to I went to the University of
South Australia in Adelaide where I'm
from doing journalism but I I didn't
finish the degree because partway
through the degree I was offered a
cadetship a newspaper amla to work for
and I took that job have you been drunk
yesterday you look a bit hungover and
sleepy I was no I was this is just
unfortunately what I look like
I always look a bit sleepy because I
don't sleep I'm too busy making videos
are you aware of internet cultures like
reddit 4chan I'm aware of reddit I could
really enjoy browsing reddit I've not
I'm aware of 4chan but it's not one that
I use what kind of fish are in your tank
it's a clownfish there will be more
videos coming on my channel food ski
which has stopped for quite a while
which is about food science but there's
a few more in the works so keep an eye
out for that I don't think I'll be
starting a yoga Journal hello to
everyone in Lithuania would you ever
kill someone to maximise your math
skills no I wouldn't do that do you
spend more time in the university in
other places I assume filming or at home
editing the videos more time is spent on
the editing overall definitely that's a
more time consuming activity but
sometimes when you feel go and film in
other countries obviously you spend a
lot of time traveling and getting to
things you film when you do those sort
of films then you spend less time
editing more time traveling and filming
where can I find numberphile merchandise
like shirts and stuff funny you should
say that because a friend of mine now
runs a business making shirts and things
like that and I've been talking to him
about I know a lot of youtubers have
shirts and stuff like that and it's
something we're starting to think about
so if you think it's something you might
be interested in leaves
and comments and ideas of things that
you might like and we might sort
something out
are you musical I am NOT I have no
musical ability I like some music I'm
going out to see a band tonight how long
is this video going to be that's a good
question it's too long already isn't it
especially with my little interlude in
the middle which I'm really sorry for
thank you for everyone who hang around
despite that okay well there's a lot of
comments now so have you ever thought
about setting up tumblers yes I have I
should do that I really like the
tumblers I've looked down or something I
haven't done yet you've just reminded me
that's something I want to look into
doing we'll all that spare time I have
everyone who's saying nice things about
the channels and thank you for
contributing everyone who's not saying
such nice things do you have a list of
all your YouTube channels if you go to
my blog which is called periodic video
so go to periodic videos blogger or
periodic videos blogspot on Google on
the right-hand side of the blog there's
like a little link saying he's a link to
all my channels and you can click on
that and when this video becomes like an
archived video and it's not live anymore
I'll go into the description and put a
list as well for people who want to
check out other channels yes it is hard
work running them all greetings from the
Netherlands greetings back to you in the
Netherlands and I'm sorry about
featuring the goal that cost you the
World Cup in our last numberphile video
I feel like a lot of people have said it
really hurt to see that and I understand
I understand
do you know minutephysics yes I do know
minutephysics as I said before he's who
makes excellent videos of course would
you do an AMA ask me anything on reddit
I would but I don't think I don't think
I'm particularly famous enough I don't
think it would be really well attended
or I don't I think it would be a smash
it
while software do you use I edit on avid
media composer which I usually like but
I don't like when it crashes what camera
equipment my main camera at the moment
is the Sony a7 but I'm about to buy
another one so any advice gratefully
received why do you have such a gorgeous
accent that's not a question I've never
been asked before my it's a hybrid
Australian and British accent do you
like Minecraft I am NOT a Minecraft er
but at Christmas it was shown to me and
I'm very intrigued by it and it looks
like something that at a time in my life
when I had time for sort of games and
activities like that I would have really
liked I think it looks really cool I can
see why people are really into it and I
actually have some minecraft ideas of
things I'd like to do with numberphile
videos and things like that so anyway
brady i saw your video on cern
which was on sixty symbols the person
said you can get work experience there i
can't find anything on the website
can you help unfortunately i can't help
because i don't actually know where on
the website it is either I think I would
just do what all of you guys would do
and Google and find things out the guy
who was in the video a guy called
Stephen Goldfarb has actually gone into
the comment section on that video which
is one of the most recent sixty symbols
videos if you haven't seen it and he
wrote an answer to someone else who
asked that comment and I had a lot to do
with talking to people at universities
and things so go and have a look in the
full comment section under that video
and some light may be shed on the
problem do you own a different shirt yes
I do
earn a different shirt this is my
favourite shirt though it is clean it's
clean every time I wear it I promise
yes we will do a number file about
imaginary numbers where are you now I'm
in my office at home
have you
shot a gun yes I have hello everyone in
Poland
someone said they missed the first 17
minutes you didn't miss much you mostly
missed me going and picking up a
computer from the front door but at the
end of this video when I shut it all
down I think YouTube will process it and
do whatever happens and then it will
become live and you can you can enjoy
that someone says they'd like to see
more viable decks which is something I
don't often see on my mathematics and
science videos and actually I filmed
some viable deck stuff today because
because of the news with the Pope
resigning I thought it was a good
opportunity to go and ask some of the
the theology experts and academics and
religion experts about what the Pope is
all about and what they think about the
resignation and hopefully I'll be
popping something onto the Bible decks
channel so because obviously I don't do
many videos for that anymore now that
we've done a video about every book of
the Bible some of these questions I
don't understand and I'm not going to
read them because they're probably some
joke I don't I don't get and I'm gonna
make a fool of myself are you on
Facebook well numberphile is on Facebook
as is a lot of my channels usually in
the video descriptions I include
Facebook addresses if you want to go and
follow their and I do put extra stuff on
Facebook that you won't find in the
videos so much how you get to do videos
like with the people that Opta you ring
up and you ask and sometimes people will
say yes and sometimes they say no but
you never know until you ask did you
attend nottingham no I did I did not I
am I do a lot of work with the
University of Nottingham but I grew up
in Australia very far away from
Nottingham I'd love to
you do a video with vihart I have done a
couple of sort of collaborations of us
of a sort with vihart I was in her video
about number two and she had made a
video for me about tetrahedral dice and
she's also in my favorite number of
videos and hopefully maybe we'll do some
other things sometime I do talk to her
occasionally she's obviously a busy a
busy lady as well
what does CGP grey look like you know
you know I can't answer that what do you
usually eat do people recognize you
not not incredibly often but
occasionally it happens usually at
strange times I'm not going to give you
a walk around my house are you
interested in hiring an editor so that
you have more free time I do need help
do you like Twitter it's okay it's I
waste a lot of time on Twitter you can
follow me on twitter at periodic videos
or at numberphile depending on which
aspect of my personality you wish to
follow will you be present in the live
chat tomorrow yes I probably will be
I'll be with James trying to make sure
it all goes smoothly and asking him
questions if you guys don't ask enough
somehow I think you were asked enough
though judging by the response today so
reminder for those who've just joined us
for the final time tomorrow Valentine's
Day February 14 I'll be here again this
time it won't just be me waffling and
reading my screen and picking up a
computer from the front door
I'll be here with dr. James grime who's
the guy that's in the most numberphile
videos of anyone and we will be talking
about whatever you want us to talk about
leave some suggestions here under this
video or just come back tomorrow it will
be at 4 p.m. UK time 11 a.m.
if you are on the East Coast in the u.s.
8:00 a.m. on the west coast of the US
and 2:30 a.m. if you often Adelaide
Australia and I don't know I could do I
could do this all day but I guess we
have to stop at some stage thank you
very much for everyone who's put
questions and comments good and bad this
has been interesting and fun for me I
don't know what it's been like for you
because you I can only see what you
write but if these things go well and
you guys show an interest we'll try and
do more of them because it's fun you
know I like you to see people as
unedited as possible that's why I make
the videos the way I do and you can't
see us more unedited then and live so
it's been fun thank you very much Cheers